bear Market rally here's the latest  buzzword you may be hearing in markets  [Music]  it's also known as a dead cat bounce  this is a sharp and rapid recovery in  the price of things like stocks bonds or  cryptocurrencies in the middle of a  long-term downtrend  they can last days or weeks or months  and can be really dangerous traps for  investors who are looking for the start  of a real recovery also known as a bull  market it can only really identify one  of these with the benefit of hindsight  this is buzzwords I'm Sphere articosta  for more of these or to ask about one of  the buzzwords you may be hearing in  markets follow us on your favorite  platforms